does this journey still even though
you're about two years out does it still
make you emotional today
yeah I get really emotional about it I'm
more so emotional about because I my
family's been through so much with
everything that I've been through in my
life and it's just like they need a
break
Erin Andrews candidly reflecting on her
journey beating cervical cancer for my
husband that was a lot to deal with to
be honest with you it could have been a
lot worse and I could have been in you
know it could have gone a different way
so thankfully it didn't and thankfully
when got tested and that's the message
we want to get out to women is they've
got to go get tested the 40-year old TV
personality tells et she credits her
family and now husband Jared stole with
getting her through it Jarrett was your
then boyfriend and the time was that
particularly challenging for your
relationship no and I think the coolest
part about it is my husband is an
athlete and I love the fact that he's so
competitive and he thinks that well as
an athlete and I think that was the one
thing you know as I remember where I'm
on the couch and my first surgery didn't
go well and I was just following my
brains out and I was screaming crying
and I remember my husband being like
it's okay babe we got this look we're
gonna beat this we got this he went into
a lot of doctors meetings saw a lot of
diagrams and sat there and I mean this
is a guy that like you know he cares
about winning faceoffs and winning you
know penalty kills and so forth and he
was like we got this we got this so no I
think if anything it made us a lot
stronger it made conversations about
having babies very you know real and
candid for him and our life and
everything so he was amazing less than a
year after learning she was cancer-free
Erin and Jared tied the knot how is
newlywed life it was fine I mean
everybody just I remember saying to us
did it feel different does it feel
different I was like no not really I
mean the crazy thing about us is from
August to January really don't see each
other
I mean it's maybe two days out of the
week maybe a day out of the week I just
went from in a week span watching
nothing but NFL videos and reading NFL
articles so now I'm like watching how to
like cut an onion like how to cut a
scallion I'm like where do you even find
a scallion so now I'm like trying to do
the opposite of like now trying to
a good wife and here I prepared this for
you I know you guys don't on that QT how
how are their plans for a real human
baby yeah there are a lot of plans and
I'll be honest I'm no spring chicken and
we're definitely working on it I am also
somebody that I'm like I got the Super
Bowl next year so let's figure this out
yeah but that's definitely in the plans
Erin's current mission she's focused on
spreading awareness of how to prevent
cervical cancer I didn't know that every
two hours a woman dies of cervical
cancer I didn't know how common it was
go get checked we need to change the
stat you can actually go to the website
change the SATCOM and learn more about
cervical cancer and we need to change it
you do need to die of this it's
preventable it's treatable but you have
to take time for yourself make an
appointment and go get checked out
[Music]